et
je suis atteint du syndrome que l'on
appelle le syndrome
de ramsay hunt
comme vous pouvez le voir cet oeil ne
cligne pas je ne peux pas sourire de ce
côté du visage cette marine ne peut pas
bouger
c'est complètement paralysé de ce côté
de mon visage
pour ceux qui sont frustrés pour
l'annulation de mai prochain concert
je ne suis juste physiquement évidemment
pas capable d'assurer mes concerts
j'espère que vous comprendrez et
je vais en profiter pour me reposer
ça fait franchement ça m'a fait
énormément de peine
c'est vrai que ce syndrome incroyable
vous avez venu parisy du visage ça peut
également avoir et on peut avoir une
perte de l'audition des éruptions
cutanées douloureuses à l'oreille au
visage les difficultés à fermer l'oeil
doit manger une sensation de vertige
donc ils vont lui prescrit un traitement
antiviral c'est franchement ça
complications d'un zona
l'air ramsey mc quand votre zone a subi
une complication alors qu'est ce qu'un
zone a dénoncé une infection c'est que
vous savez c'est comme une réactivation
de la varicelle cesseront quand on est
enfant c'est pas si grave que ça quand
on est adulte ça peut être dangereux et
puis ça apparaît en période de stress
quand on a une baisse d'immunité en
l'occurrence l'huile à la maladie de
lyme et il a une mononucléose chronique
qui fait qu'il a il qu'il est sujet au
stress avec sa vie donc voilà nous
pourrons alors il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont dit on ne voit pas les ce qu'on
appelle les pustules dans sa dans sa
vidéo mais rex et à l'intérieur de
l'oreille et c'est très sournois alors
la seule note d'optimisme c'est que
comme ça a été pris à temps on peut
espérer qu'il n'est pas de séquelles
mais sinon il peut y avoir une surdité
et alors là pour un chanteur évidemment
d'euros mais ce serait dramatique il est
gentil
28 chez les fans de justin bieber il ya
plusieurs théories du complot il y en a
qui disent que c'est à cause du vaccin
contre le colonisateur les vacciner il
ya plusieurs mois y en a d'autres qui
disent que c'est à cause des substances
qui n'a pu prendre parce qu'il a fait un
documentaire dans lequel il révélé qu'il
a été a dicté à la drogue a priori ça
n'aurait rien à voir avec ça c'est une
maladie qui lie à la varicelle quand on
est sûrs si on était en sang plein de
gens disent que ça cause du vaccin et
sur les femmes et la paire d'ailés dix
ans il va arriver à la retrouver parce
que sans les pustules qui bouchent les
oreilles bien d'accord
j'en ai eu à des postulants oui pas là
non c'est les pustules quillan intérieur
de l'oreille je répète ribéry mais je le
sais j'étais instruit chagas
pustules dans l'oreille salut bouche
l'audition s'est passée j'ai eu ça moi
c'est pas sûr qu'ils retrouvent
totalement l'audition c'est 3 à 4
semaines on en saura plus dans trois à
quatre semaines zikiz
été victime d'un petit avc ya pas
longtemps donc comme quoi ça n'arrive
dauphin ça arrive aux jeunes il faut
faire attention et c'est bien qu'ils en
parlent comme ça sur les réseaux parce
que l ceux à qui ça arrive bézid bah moi
mon nez on n'est pas seuls et voici ce
qu'il disait